e sì la domanda è proprio questa che
cosa mangeremo forse non nel 2029 ma
molto prima già tra un anno due perché
ciò di cui parleremo oggi sta arrivando
sta arrivando
perché effettivamente ci sono molte
aziende nel mondo che molte numerose
start up e alcune aziende che stanno
iniziando a lavorare sulla carne
coltivata in alcuni casi sono molto
vicini alla commercializzazione per
capire di cosa stiamo parlando perché
questo è un termine che forse avete
sentito così come forse avrete sentito
parlare di carne in vitro o carne
artificiale vari sinonimi con cui queste
sostanze sono chiamate partirei da
questo che è un pollo come vedete che si
chiama ian questo pollo non avrebbe
niente di particolare se non fosse che
le persone che vedete sulla destra cioè
i fondatori di questa startup che si
chiama just che californiana stanno
mangiando delle crocchette che sono
fatte con la sua carne ma non come la
intendiamo noi cioè col collo macellato
e poi lavorato sono fatte prelevando
semplicemente delle pochissime cellule
di ian e sottoponendo a una serie di
cose che vedremo
questi ragazzi di just non sono gli
unici come accennavo vi ho portato
alcuni esempi di cose che stanno
arrivando che attendono probabilmente
soltanto le autorizzazioni governative
dei diversi paesi e abbiamo per esempio
la menphis smith che ormai una grande
azienda che fa pollo fana tra fa maiale
fa altre cose abbiamo un'esperienza
molto interessante che è quella
israeliana di all'est mit perché in
israele hanno realizzato la prima
bistecca colti con carne coltivata e
sono concentrati ovviamente tutte le
carnico share e questo è un dettaglio
non da poco perché dimostra che queste
carni
possono essere appunto possono
rispondere esigenze anche culturali
religiose molto specifiche
poi abbiamo invece i due esempi di pesce
uno viene ancora dalla california della
fim food che è un'azienda di san
francisco in cui sono riusciti a far
crescere in vitro la carne di tonno
oltre che di pesce molto normali come il
merluzzo e abbiamo un esempio invece
orientale che è molto interessante
perché in oriente consumo di gamberetti
ha delle dimensioni di cui noi non ci
rendiamo neanche conto e quindi ha un
problema molto serio e questa azienda di
singapore la shock ha già realizzato dei
gamberetti cresciuti in vitro
cerchiamo di capire così a volo
d'uccello naturalmente come si fa a
coltivare la carne in generale per
qualunque tipo di carne lo schema è
sempre lo stesso cioè si prende
l'animale desiderato diciamo così si
prelevano con una biopsia quindi come
nel pollo con una semplice puntura
un'iniezione si preleva delle cellule
muscolari muscolari che di solito sono
anche miste ad altre cellule si isolano
queste cellule muscolari poco
differenziato meglio non differenziata e
di solito sono staminali si mettono in
cultura finché diventano delle fibre si
sottopongono ai trattamenti meccanici e
poi si ottiene la polpa tenete presente
che quello che ha finora ostacolato la
grande la crescita lo sviluppo di queste
sistemi di cultura di carne sono è
proprio il passaggio della crescita in
cultura nel senso che in tutti i
laboratori del mondo si è sempre
ottenuto uno strato di cellule per usi
per esempio biologici medici e così via
però non si riusciva a ottenere la polpa
quello che queste aziende questi
ricercatori e anche tanti centri tanti
centri universitari hanno ottenuto è
invece la capacità di sviluppare delle
vere e proprie fibre dei tessuti che
quindi possono diventare carne in questo
caso siccome quello che si cerca sono
sempre cellule muscolari si è capito che
oltre a usare dei mezzi di cultura
particolari
se si sottopongono queste cellule a una
sollecitazione meccanica cioè banalmente
le si fa crescere attorno per esempio un
cilindro che si agita questo favorisce
la crescita e quindi nel tempo da luogo
proprio a dei tessuti come li avete
visti
ecco adesso il passaggio successivo
naturalmente è ottenere grandi quantità
di queste carni perché un conto è avere
una piastra in un laboratorio un conto è
pensare di offrire queste carni come
alternativa sostenibile e eticamente
valida per milioni e milioni di persone
anche solo per i cittadini di san
francisco per esempio ci si sta
lavorando molto soprattutto perché si
cerca di mantenere un livello altissimo
di sostenibilità cioè non si vogliono
mettere nei in questi incubatori che
vedete sulla destra delle cose che poi
siano a loro volta poco sostenibili cioè
se io faccio la carne in vitro e quindi
elimino tutta una serie di problemi
associati alla carne e però poi ci metto
qualsiasi cosa evidentemente un corto
circuito che non va bene quindi questo è
il momento in cui siamo ci sono anche
delle difficoltà normative perché non si
ha ancora deciso esattamente come
classificare questi prodotti nel senso
che ci vorranno dai controlli ma non
esistono delle agenzie specifiche allora
si discute tra il farmaceutico
l'agricolo quindi però queste aziende
che vi ho fatto vedere dicono tutti che
entro un anno due arriveranno nei
supermercati
nel frattempo quelli che stanno
studiando queste sostanze hanno però già
fatto dei passi in avanti molto
interessanti da tanti punti di vista
questo è un incubatore domestico nel
senso che molti di appunto di queste
start up propongono già oggi proprio
degli elettrodomestici come un normale
frullatore da mettere nella propria
cucina
questa sembra una cosa molto naif in
realtà lo è meno di quello che appunto
potrebbe sembrare
perché tenete presente che se io ho
nella mia cucina un assortimento di
unità di base di cellule di qualsiasi
cosa posso intanto creare nelle carni
che non esistono in natura e questo è un
elemento che stimola la curiosità è che
per un certo numero di persone può
essere un'attrazione ma soprattutto io
potrei pensare di fare delle carni che
hanno dei profili nutrizionali
desiderati per esempio se io devo avere
poco colesterolo oppure se ho una
carenza di domenica una dieta appunto
particolare un solo un anziano avendo il
mio sintetizzatore il mio incubatore
domestico posso sicuramente pensare di
fare la carne secondo le mie esigenze e
oltretutto naturalmente non mettendo
tutta una serie di cose che oggi sono
presenti nelle carni normali che io
invece non voglio questo è anche uno
strumento che viene utilizzato pensando
a come fare per aumentare l'accettazione
da parte del pubblico perché ciascuno di
voi come me di fronte istintivamente di
fronte al nome carne coltivate in
laboratorio questa dicitura a una
reazione di repulsione non è una cosa a
cui siamo abituati ma effettivamente se
poi andiamo a vedere alcune
caratteristiche capiremo anche meglio
perché ha un senso perché probabilmente
avrà un posto nelle nostre cucine allora
tutti coloro che la stanno promuovendo
stanno cercando di pensare come fare per
farla accettare questa è un'esperienza
questa è un'altra esperienza molto
carina che vi ho portato perché in
giappone esiste un grande progetto
pubblico che si chiama punto sorge in
med che coinvolge moltissimi ragazzi
delle scuole che a scuola hanno già
avuto
già da un paio d'anni dei piccoli
sintetizzatori per cui giocando bambini
elementari giocano con questi strumenti
e per facilitare la diffusione nel
pubblico e creare diciamo una
generazione che abbia assoluta
familiarità con queste cose hanno
assoldato reclutato nel loro team anche
anche tutti i disegnatori di manga e
diffondono a disegni come questo
quindi questo per dire che a livello
mondiale c'è un grande sforzo per
rendere queste case in coltivata la
normalità dei prossimi anni a partire
già dai bambini che sapore ha perché
naturalmente la cosa che viene spontaneo
chiedersi no cioè benissimo
tutto molto bello però se poi è
immangiabile anche un discorso
abbastanza inutile invece sono stati
organizzati e vengono continuamente
organizzati dei panel di assaggio quello
che ho riportato sulla sinistra è la
poule primo diciamo essere umano che ha
assaggiato questa carne
cosa che è avvenuta nel 2013 a londra
perché il guardian ha organizzato un
assaggio con la prima carne sintetizzata
in vitro che è stata fatta da un
ricercatore olandese che si chiama mark
post che
dell'università di maastricht e quindi
questa è la foto del primo assaggio
sulla destra ci sono c'è uno degli
esempi dei tanti pane che ci sono in
giro per il mondo in genere per il
momento solo di nutrizionisti o
giornalisti food blogger esperti
psicologi del cibo per verificare che
siano poi prodotti accettabili ed
effettivamente tutti diciamo per
sintetizzare dicono che è una carne
perfettibile ma molto molto simili alle
carni originali per esempio shaun vald
ha detto che sapeva di polpettone un po
asciutta però sapeva di polpettone cioè
non è una cosa che ha poi un gusto che è
assolutamente diverso da quello a cui
siamo abituati
quindi cerchiamo qui vi ho portato
semplicemente uno dei numerosissimi
schemi che potete trovare in rete
sull'impatto della carne tradizionale
perché la domanda è ma è davvero
necessaria abbiamo davvero bisogno di
questa avanzamento di questo avanzamento
tecnologico per riuscire a nutrire
diciamo i 10 miliardi di esseri umani
che ci saranno entro il 2050 secondo
tutte le stime
la risposta è sì probabilmente sarà una
delle tante cose nuove che vedremo nei
prossimi anni
naturalmente non vi leggo i dettagli
però la carne di manzo di pollo di
maiale alla canna di allevamento anche
quella biologica ha un impatto
sull'ambiente che anche se non è
percepito così grave in realtà è molto
molto grave nel senso che a livello di
acqua terreni emissioni di gas rifiuti
energia elettrica consumo di acqua
i numeri sono spaventosi e lo dicono
tutte le agenzie governative e la fao e
qualsiasi ente di ricerca va da
quantificare l'impatto ambientale della
carne per non parlare poi del problema
degli antibiotici delle infezioni
alimentari che nascono negli allevamenti
e così via
dice che la filiera alimentare
industriale come è strutturata oggi
non può reggere non può andare avanti e
tantomeno potrà nutrire per l'appunto 10
miliardi di esseri umani che è il numero
che tutti danno a prescindere
badate bene dalla fertilità cioè il
numero di sostituzione anche se nessuno
di noi facesse più figli nel 2050 saremo
10 miliardi quindi bisogna fare qualcosa
vi ho portato le alternative perché in
questi giorni si parla moltissimo di
questi hamburger che sono vegani
cosiddetti perché finalmente pare che si
sia riuscito a raggiungere un gusto
molto molto simile alla carne vorrei
richiamare semplicemente la vostra
attenzione su qualche dettaglio
innanzitutto sono prodotti che sono
presenti in commercio da un sacco di
anni quello che è stato fatto adesso è
stato di aggiungere delle sostanze che
in alcuni casi sono dei succhi vegetali
in un caso ed emoglobina cioè la
principale proteina del sangue e quindi
raggiungere una similitudine rispetto
alla carne normale molto molto
soddisfacente dal punto di vista
aziendale
vorrei però ricordare che l'emoglobina è
la principale sospettata da parte mia ma
da parte dello iarc che l'agenzia che si
occupa di ricerca sul cancro dell'oms di
essere la responsabile del aumento di
rischio di cancro del colon associato
alle carni rosse
quindi forse prendere un hamburger
vegano che sicuramente meglio di un
hamburger di manzo però è pieno di
emoglobina
non so forse merita una riflessione in
più così come merita una riflessione il
fatto che questi prodotti sono prodotti
a base di in altissime percentuali di
farine vegetali di farina e per esempio
di piselli o di soia o di patate e
naturalmente per renderlo ma appunto
appetibile della differenza della carne
coltivata che è quello è solo carne sono
pieni zeppi di insaporitori conservanti
e additivi
cioè sono dei prodotti ad altissimo
contenuto tecnologico che anche se hanno
questo aspetto così bello è vegano e
sostenibile sono questa cosa qui cioè
non è un pezzo di pianta che sa di carne
è qualcos'altro
va benissimo però bisogna saperlo
un'altra alternativa verso cui si sta
andando è questa cioè naturalmente chi
fa hamburger cerca di andare verso la
sostenibilità questo è un ristorante che
c'è già senza la cisco ea boston che si
chiama di creator modestamente e cioè in
grado di fare 120 hamburg al minuto come
volete e che ha eliminato totalmente il
fattore umano
naturalmente questo comporta un certo
risparmio è anche un efficientamento di
quello che era il consumo di energia
elettrica acqua e così via
però forse non è la soluzione ai
problemi che ci troviamo davanti vedremo
un'altra alternativa è l'alternativa
classica cioè andare avanti col sistema
di adesso io vi ho portato questo perché
è molto significativo in questi giorni
forse avrete notato che una delle
principali aziende di fast food
mcdonald's fa una grande campagna
soprattutto in italia ma anche in altri
paesi
difendendo e pubblicizzando la sua
svolta sostenibile perché ha le filiere
italiane perché nei ristoranti adottato
dei materiali a meno plastica e così via
tutto molto bello il problema è che
questo tipo di provvedimento risolve
soltanto una piccola parte dell'impatto
della carne
nel senso che diminuisce leggermente
l'impatto che ha il trasporto avere una
bistecca un manzo che dal brasile arriva
in volo in nave in europa e poi viene
portato il cuore di milano
naturalmente si arriva da lodi
chiaramente consuma meno e mette meno ma
è questa una piccola parte perché se poi
lo stesso hamburger mi costa doppio come
vedete sulla destra 50 centesimi
è evidente che c'è qualcosa che non
funziona tanto più che vi basti pensare
un dato per fare
un hamburger occorrono 15 mila litri di
acqua anche solo l'acqua non può costare
50 centesimi questo è il concorrente che
prosegue su questa strada avrete visto
queste pubblicità martellanti di tripli
hamburger sempre di più con bacon con
tante cose quindi questo è dove
vorrebbero che continuassimo diciamo ad
andare per cui l'unica cosa che io vi
vorrei lasciare oggi è una domanda che
spero che ciascuno di voi si faccia non
tanto per noi ma per il futuro anche dei
nostri figli
una domanda a cui io non ho risposta
ognuno trovi la sua ma quando entriamo
in un fast food
se decidiamo di entrare e quando andiamo
in un banale supermercato
la domanda dovrebbe sempre essere che
cosa sto comprando ha veramente senso
questo tipo di alimentazione o ci sono
delle alternative tanto cibo futuro
quando ci saranno in alternativa in cui
vi parlavo perché anche se nessuno di
noi ne fondo così convinto però vi
assicuro che quello che fa veramente la
differenza il comportamento di ciascuno
di noi
anche decidendo di andare o meno
infastidito di comprare o meno un
hamburger
quindi io l'unica cosa che vi posso
lasciare è una domanda
niente di più
[Applauso]